i don't know if you can see vancouver in
the distance
but uh just enough for some
cross-country skiing
and uh sun's going down so i'm heading
in
uh i thought i might choose this as the
opportunity to announce my
study plans for the next little while
i'm gonna go on a 90 continue my 90-day
challenge where i'm doing both arabic
and farsi so that'll be january february
march
then april may i'm going to focus on
slavic languages because i'm going to
ukraine in may
i've been
providing some monetary assistance to an
nga in eastern ukraine i'm going to go
visit these ladies that are
helping vulnerable people over there so
i'm gonna have two weeks in ukraine so
i'm gonna be speaking ukrainian and
russian there so i'm gonna ramp up to
that by reading novels and literature
and see if i can improve my accuracy and
cases and stuff in slavic languages
oh and at the end of my 90 days of
arabic and farsi i will do an interview
in each one of those languages just to
see how far i've come
and then later in the year i'm going to
do a 90-day concentration on asian
languages japanese korean and maybe some
chinese
because i'm going to go to the polyglot
conference in fukuoka
so i'm going to ramp up so i'm going to
be doing some
middle eastern some slavic and some
asian
uh so just to update you on that
and uh not get better head down because
my son's waiting for me bye for now
and this is the following morning
as i look out
on eagle harbor
the sun is rising but there's clouds off
in the distance coming off and i keep
riding
some kind of a hover craft making a lot
of noise
and uh another day dawn's here in
vancouver
and
uh
hi there steve kaufman here
so
uh lovely skiing yesterday on uh
cypress mountain
and uh i mentioned that uh
you know i was planning for my upcoming
year as far as language learning is
concerned
and of course these planes are plans are
somewhat subject to change but i think
they're going to stick to it
so uh just to go over what that means in
detail
uh and remember that that language
learning to me is a matter of an input
strategy you have to have a strategy
on what is going to constitute sort of
beneficial and compelling input at
different stages in our learning
so
for
the first period now in fact it's what
i've been doing for the last
quite a few months
where i'm focusing on arabic and farsi
i'm going to spend most of my time on
the many stories and maybe who is she
uh which is what i have been doing some
of the many stories i've listened to 30
40 times as i get to the later ones of
course i haven't listened to them as
often but i hope to get them up to 30 40
times
and the goal with the many stories and i
found that many stories i can't say it
enough so powerful
because of the repetition
uh each story is four minutes five
minutes long
the key vocabulary repeats four or five
times six times in each story
um
there not tremendously interesting but i
find that because i'm trying to get a
hold of the
of the structures of the language and
because these stories
include the most frequent verbs of the
language so all of the i want i need
i have to i go i come i take
all of these things uh
come up
regularly they're built around these
most common verbs these stories
and
sort of the in order to therefore
because why since all of those kinds of
words that you need to sort of structure
what it is you want to say they're all
in there and they're repeated and
repeated and so every time i listen even
a story that i've listened to 30 times
i'll pick something up new in terms of a
structure
or there are words that i still don't
quite get so i or i've forgotten so i
have to go back in and read it
sometimes when i'm reviewing the stories
i'll just go through the flash cards for
that story because i know most the words
i just want to again focus my attention
on those words and phrases that i've had
trouble with so
with arabic and farsi very much focused
on the many stories
and those are to me compelling input
because i'm trying to get a toehold in
in the language
now when i go to my you know warming up
for my visit to ukraine the sort of
slavic period
uh with islamic languages i want to get
i want to become more accurate i want to
become more accurate in the use of the
language and the use of cases in the use
of
verbs of motion and this kind of thing
and therefore with the slavic languages
i will again go through our many stories
all 60 of them we have them in ukrainian
we have them
in in russian we have them in czech
slovak polish whatever but we have them
in those two languages
i will also
regularly
visit the grammar rule not to try to
remember it but to remind myself
and we have by the way at link now we've
developed a bunch of simplified grammars
like maximum 6 000 word grammars of a
bunch of languages including ukrainian
and russian so i'll be going through
that again just to hopefully try to
trigger my brain to try to get better at
on the fly being able to produce a
correct case and the correct form of the
verb
but with the russian and ukrainian
i will vary that sort of mini-story
exposure to
reading literature i have so much
material especially in russian but even
in ukrainian history books literature
where i have the audiobook and the text
i can import the text into link and i
can acquire more words my biggest
problem in
in in russia i have a lot of words but i
still struggle with the structure so
i'll be combining those two things with
ukrainian i think i can again i have a
lot of words in ukrainian but again i
want to and i want to see if i can
clearly distinguish in my mind between
ukrainian and russian so that'll be my
focus with the slavic languages
then later on in the year as i prefer
prepare for my visit to
to a to asia to japan possibly korea
i'm going to be doing korean with a
korean i still don't have that
confidence that i can just talk on a
variety of subjects so with korean i
have to a get better at my use of the
structure and b i have to acquire more
words so with korean i will also do the
mini stories
and i will again the problem with korean
it's a bit like
getting back to my arabic i i can do the
mini stories but when i go to the next
level which is genuine authentic you
know podcasts from al jazeera or
whatever it is it's just too big big a
leap and the same is true with korean we
have some podcasts at link on politics
on literature it's too big a leap so i
have to try to move myself closer to
where
i can do these uh more difficult
authentic and more interesting types of
content
so i kind of be varying it more whereas
with the arabic and farsi i'm
predominantly
many stories with my korean i'll be kind
of 50 50.
uh
with japanese and chinese i'll be
looking to increase my vocabulary uh
reading things on link where i can
easily look things up
i have some audiobooks
and some other audio material in chinese
and japanese for which i have the text
so that's what i'll be doing there so
that's just to give you a sense of how
my input strategy
er you know the kind of input strategy
that i have and it's course dependent on
where i am in the language
so
that's all i had to say and
see you later
[Music]
you